everybody always want to know what we
got going on in our new crib
you excited don't be shy i want it
through this door
let's just get into it your house is
fairly
very new
atl we have our new york times article
so you can get front page
front page we got our instagram
[Music]
[Music]
here we have our back patio we'll play
football
and everything out here we may get a
pool have a nice little pool party
from here you can see the back of the
house and this is what it looks like
[Music]
okay
[Music]
a room that we have i think that's a
nice feature
this is kamara's girl cave where she is
so we already have like this little
couch you know saying a little tv
i'm trying to get it put up on the wall
at this moment but this is where i just
sit here
edit come up with content yes slovak
these are our beds this is my side
that's my
size chico yeah that's chica he'll be
chilling
so over here is where we edit and i'll
be like okay friend
oh hey friend what's your everything um
oh yeah this is
[Music]
this is my side and then we have a tub
like i said everyone doesn't have a
shower
but it's so nice if you get to the lace
it's like that's in it
sounds like a little jacuzzi
the boys picked this up but i feel like
we need a little girl's touch to the
house for sure
like a little glitter one little little
wall maybe a wall without
exactly i think i should come back when
we have a fully furnished house tour
fully furnished oh my god you got to
come back
meantime
thank you entertainment tonight thank
you it was nice having you
but you gotta go now see you later
[Music]
bye